[Music]
i'm chris distefano i am
sal volcano there you go yeah and uh it
sounded like you said saddle
hey do you want to do it again do it
again i'm sad i didn't see now
now it's in my head yeah i'm saddle your
saddle i'm salvatore really
should we name the podcast saddles with
blazing saddles
christopher christopher you get cold all
the time i rarely get called salvatore
salvatore my mother calls me christopher
yeah
all the time my name is christopher paul
anthony decefino
paul was my dad said so
i was born in august 26 1984 christopher
paul de stefano anthony's confirmation
everybody's got a b day coming up yeah i
got a b day coming up
but but my dad wanted to name me joe
just
j.o.e joe not joseph just joe and then
wanted to change my middle name
sometime around early 1985 because he
had read
around christmas time that the number
one name of 1984 amongst homosexual men
was paul
so my dad what is what literature is he
reading my dad
well that's the question my mother had
was like tony what
why annual yeah what are you reading
you're that's the thing with my dad it's
been
you know my whole life has been like
you're so are you gay don't you wonder
where your parents get their information
because my parents dropped some bombs on
me
and i'm like where have you read this
and they're like i read it
what does it matter what does it matter
yeah i mean well your dad you know i met
your dad a few times i mean he's the
most diesel 70 year old i've ever met
apple side event when's the when do you
think you have to guess
is the last day he's not taking a shot
of apple cider vinegar
uh two decades so you you you would say
20 years
in a row consecutively hasn't missed a
day
that's bragg's organic apple cider
vinegar with the mother
apparently the mother is like all that
called the mother yeah it's all the
extra like coagulated bits in there that
give you the real nutrients yeah
he says it's a cure all it's an appetite
suppressant
it's it's it's good for high blood
pressure it helps you sleep it warms off
infections
blah blah blah he takes it all the time
god bless him he puts it in a shot glass
with uh a teaspoon of raw honey
and he does it every single day uh guys
the guy's rarely sick
well i'll tell you when we were doing
when i did your cruise when i was on the
impractical jokers cruise
um a few months ago i
was worried about your father because i
hadn't seen him about three or four days
we're on the high seas
and then i went to the gift shop and i
saw that
one apple cider vinegar container had
been bought and then i knew he was safe
i said he's still here because i said to
the lady when was the spot
and she said about an hour ago i said
you're sure
she's i didn't even have to ask who it
was i said i know who it is and i just
he's safe in his room did you ever take
it i've taken yeah i told you
it's pretty pungent i would take that's
not an easy swallow
i would take that with i gotta stop
wearing shorts if we're gonna do
podcasts by the way
i got bruises and my legs are pasty
freaking white
full disclosure i was in shorts we did a
check to see what we looked like on
camera right i
felt like it looked like drop of the
heart i told you that i told you john
now that i felt like i look like i'm i
kind of look like job of the hunt and i
have to do everything i can
to then make you believe i don't look
like childhood but then what you also
said was funny you said i put on jeans
because i don't want to look like a
salted ham
yeah that's what you said that's right
it's funny for the human beings
feels as if they look like a salted ham
sometimes
salt and ham is very appealing you ever
see you ever work at a deli
well i've never worked in a deli but
before just just i just so you clear and
the audience is clear
you're gonna i think about to ask me if
i've ever had salted ham and the answer
quickly is no because i've also told you
i've never had a pork chop
goat cheese and never seen the movie the
godfather so you need to know the no
know those three things about me if
we're going to start this podcast which
is insane so we just ordered lunch which
is on the way
and i ordered a pork chop and you
reminded me what i what i knew which is
a pork chop and by the way pork chop
maybe my favorite
cut of meat for dinner i don't have it
often and maybe that's why
but it is when it's done right it's
harder to cook but it's lean
and perfect and juicy and succulent it's
not as heavy
as a steak and it's not as shitty as
it's a real nice cut of meat right i i
is there a reason you haven't had a pork
chop i don't think
my mother i'm sorry my my aunt told me
when i was a kid that if you put salt on
a pork chop and leave it out in the sun
maggots will come out of it
which i think is true for any meat but
she told me
i don't know if that's true you don't
mean like you mean they have to first
grow bake in the heat and then grow just
like any other bacteria you don't think
there's just
you don't think there's like uh benign
maggots in pork chops that just don't
come out unless they get salted
i thought any piece of meat like if i
had a chicken cutlet right now and i
left it out in the sun maggots would
come out of it
how long i thought i don't know
raw but i could but here's the thing raw
raw oh raw
rough yeah yeah i mean yeah if you leave
a piece of
raw meat out in the sun over time you're
going to get maggots
if you leave a body out in the sun over
time you're going to get maggots but
does that mean that the maggots are
inside my body right now and they get
activated with the sun
no i don't think there's maggots that
are just keeping it on the down so the
weight of the maggots come from inside
the body if i haven't touched the body
for me it's unclear and i don't want to
speak
i don't want to make you feel like i
have authority on maggots
yeah i'm and i don't really know much
about much but but i think that what
happens is
bacteria begins to form and then
something could joils about
right and then something connects and
then maggots come out of that like
they're bird out of like in like like uh
like like cells or something like uh
bacteria
it's very i don't know but but it's just
always been a mind
what happens let me blow you mind one
more step yeah what happens when you
leave maggots out in the sun
do maggots come out of maggots who knows
that's the kind of questions we're
asking here on this podcast we don't
know what the podcast is yet we don't
know what the podcast is and we don't
know the name yet we're thinking right
now hey babe
with chris and sal or sal and chris
present hey babe
we don't know what to call it i mean i
don't think we've ever addressed each
other without saying hey babe first
hey babe first you know other podcasts
his ideas and i was like you know what
that makes sense to you yeah
and then you know would our fan base be
the hey babes the haze could be the
babes could be the babies could be the
babes
but it's just one of those things where
we're not sure yet we just wanted to
start a podcast because
we um we feel uh that we
you know we have we have we have we have
a lot of fun together so we've been
trying to start a podcast for like over
a year over here meet you and tim dillon
yeah but then tim dillon moved out to
l.a
and has moved into the desert that ship
has sailed yeah
that yeah that that ship has sailed but
uh he's moving in the desert
but no we always like we always we go on
the road together a lot always yeah and
we always find ourselves in laughing
fits
hysterically we're just like why don't
we just try to like uh bring the joy to
other people no dude i'm down for it i i
i'm
i'm excited to do this we have our man
homeless pimp uh
which which by the way we've said some
of the hardest we've ever laughed is
you know we like a guy who's got a funny
name a wild name
you know i don't know him personally but
anytime we hear machine gun kelly
it's just a very very it's a it's very
funny to think about we were in denver
yeah with uh pete davidson was
performing there
and it was one of those things where
pete davidson hangs out with machine gun
kelly a lot
and uh we're in the green room of the
denver comedy works we're about to go
and then i said to salas do you want to
go over to denver comedy works
they were in the group you were you were
doing you and i you were headlining the
theater
i was opening for you at the theater and
then pete was headlining comedy works
denver he was just there with him ricky
he like did that thing pete could do
that it's great she shows up
shea and pete do that yeah i think
they're like i think i'm gonna perform
this weekend at this place and then
there's like eight
shows i i was like i mean i was
very lucky to perform at the paramount i
think it was who i think they share
i think they run i think it's all like
the same owners of bookers yeah you know
yeah but i was happy but i do have to
sell for like six to eight months to get
that done
and it's one of those things where it's
like you know where
where where comics are the comics you
know they're they're there
in denver and we're like you know what
let's go hang out and then you know
ricky texts me
great ricky villains great comic uh
awesome good friend of mine
and he's um and he says he says yeah he
goes you know there's room in here it's
a little tight
he said because you know pete's here and
then also machine gun kelly and then you
have to ask yourself
i'm a fan of machine gun kelly's music
is a salad you have to ask you you know
i said to myself we're in the van on the
way there
and i said you know i got a
three-year-old daughter sal's 40.
are we gonna be in a are we at a point
in our lives right now
where we want to be sharing a space
albeit we're fans with the guy who goes
by machine gun kelly
yeah has that ship sailed and you know
it's nothing against him no
he might be terrific it's just that
something comes with a name
right i just said to you i feel like job
of the hut yeah
so you when i say that you get a sense
of what i mean right when someone has an
automatic weapon in their name
in their name yeah i don't know what
we're stepping into you know one day you
want to have a family and all that and i
have my daughter and i just feel like
you know right you know the machine gun
kelly it's like something you do when
you're in your 20s you know you want to
have a party a little bit
not those guys are still in their 20s i
think well pete is right pizza is 20
young kids ricky might be 30ish
but they're still very distant you know
what uh they still haven't
uh worried like they have never thought
minute on the lips
lifetime on the hips they have never
thought about that they're very thin and
i don't think they work at it yeah which
by the way that sets us apart
ricky velez if you don't know ricky
velez if you should know his comedy but
just in case you don't he was in pete's
movie king of uh staten island
um which just came out great movie go
check it out but ricky's what i loved it
what
was funny to me about that movie is when
ricky got shot
in the movie you're gonna see it's i was
probably oh you haven't seen it no i
want to i just told you ricky got shot
sorry he gets shot ricky gets shot that
must have been so fun to shoot at i ask
him about it ricky gets shot and then
goes to jail
but then you never find out what
happened to him you never find out
anything get out
get out the movie just ends and you're
like all right well i guess i'm just
gonna have to constantly not think about
is ricky dead or alive and how long was
his prison term wow
yeah but so but but more so we were
laughing because we always we were
pontificating what do you call machine
gun kelly
when you when you know him like he said
you call him machine do you call him
machine or like what about when he's
going to the doctor's office is it is it
mr kelly i wonder where mr machine do
you know if his real name
he's not kelly that's a whole moniker is
machine gun kelly's
yeah mike's going to look oh they
probably call him his real name which i
don't know what it is
but they wouldn't tell us that bill
smith is there because we don't know who
that is right so ricky has to tell you
machine gun kelly
and then we say like i don't know if i
would go high machine gun kelly
yeah i don't know what i would say yeah
hey yeah mr mr machine or yeah mr gunn
it's the gun oh
oh god okay so his name is richard
oh cool i remember that coulson yeah
coulson yeah oh i thought his first name
was
richard coulson baker so rick rich they
call him rich
i don't know like but what do you call
any of these people like i don't know
you know like what do you call freaking
um
anybody weekend the weekend what do you
call the weekend hi the weekend
either weekend and you don't want to
disrespect you don't you don't want to
shorten it you don't say well it's a
weekend yeah you don't know me like that
yeah like what are you saying like hey
weekend please my father was weekend
call me the
no no yeah like yeah the weekend yeah
what do you call it yeah i don't know
they probably call him his real name
that's probably what it is does anybody
know do we make a mistake not making
like fake like names for ourself for the
public it's one of those things
i think we did in a sense but it's one
of those things what would be your name
where it's like i don't know what my
name would be
what are you talking about you name you
have a hundred nicknames i know
i know i have a hundred it's chrissy
then whatever you feel
whatever yeah christy conquistador yeah
chrissy [ __ ] hips like whatever
whatever
crystal clear chrissy crystal clear
chrissy chrissy conspiracies yeah um
chrissy colonoscopies
i just yeah i could just so i guess i do
have the names but i
feel as if like being a white guy in
entertainment
we're not we don't we go by usually the
first and last name and a black comedian
usually
will go by a nickname or just their
first name like a natural disaster
yeah earthquake yeah so he goes on tour
with um
tsunam and uh
um i think um yeah i think i think yeah
as far as that goes i mean
machine gun kelly it's interesting i
just always remember anytime i think of
denver
i think of us laughing about machine gun
kelly about just
i don't know how to say hello yeah i
don't have to say hello no i know he
probably goes hey i'm rich
but it's but the thing is with guys like
sal and i is we
sat you have to understand normal people
would say oh we don't know what we're
calling but we'll figure out when we get
there sal and i didn't show up
because we weren't sure what to call
machine gun kelly so i made up an excuse
that said we're not coming and then we
just went to sal's room and smoked
sativia yeah that's
that's sativas you put
no this is no but like that is how i
live my life and i also wonder how i
have any even mild success
because i am a coward yeah yeah same way
i'm scared no i'm
not coward but i i i won't back down and
i'll stay on my ground but i also i'm
scared of a lot
right i'm scared i confronted not
confrontation you know what no you know
what i take everything i just said back
i'm
talking i'm free associating my feelings
right now and i realize that was
misguided
i i don't like to be met with any type
of
opposition not i don't mean opposition
but like you're not confrontational
if there's an issue chrissy
confrontational we wouldn't be friends
right right but if you if we're like
uh do we are we supposed to hang out
machine gun kelly right
i would say like i i don't even want to
i don't even want to find out
right exactly yeah and that's kind of
being your friend now for
that's probably why i never ended up
with cindy crawford and i had a chance
and you had a chance but yeah
you were like what am i going to do
because i know it'd be great can you
imagine i would
she was my number one yeah uh it was
alyssa milano in like grammar school but
then when i got to
college yeah cindy crawford i would say
the most
the thing in that i've masturbated to
the most in my life sure is jamie lee
curtis dancing
in true lies true lies because there's a
little bit of a nip slip around minute
uh 4701
you've seen trading places no i've never
seen trading places or the godfather
you've nev you've never seen traders
with dan aykroyd and and eddie murphy
no i got a story about dan aykroyd
though let's hear it yeah
have you ever tell you this story about
daniel cory i don't believe so okay i'll
stop
i mean even if i have i won't stop you
so they can hear okay so dan axe so
again the thing is my dad sometimes
tells tall tales yeah
but when my mother co-signs it then you
know it's true
sure so my mom very young when she was
pregnant
23 24 years old beautiful woman and my
dad's like you know just my dad
right so they're out my mother's
pregnant they're laying in central park
they got a she has a blanket covering
her your dad went to
a picnic date yeah my dad would i don't
even from what i know i can't even
believe i'm telling you that i'm telling
you
he was definitely in like black socks oh
100 yeah
black socks freaking yankees batting
practice jersey 100
yeah so so so my dad
you know people like like like a little
like a salami log
yeah like just something and but then
didn't cut it on crackers you just bit
it like a bit of like that well do
i ever tell you about the time real
quick my dad here's what me and you are
gonna need to do
is we uh we might be able to call this
like adhd because we go
we have to remember what to come back to
what should we call this podcast to tell
you about
the time did i tell you about the time
that's on the that's on the table so
okay okay so so go salami go back to dan
aykroyd then i'll come back to trading
places with jamie curtis that's what
we'll do so we'll do one two three so
wait so
i'm gonna go with the salami first to
get us to tell troy to get us back to
central park and then i want to end with
training places curtis so so so
my um dad when i was like 13 14 years
old i had
he used to come to my mother's house to
watch me or whatever
and we had a dog named cruella it was a
dalmatian we named cruella
and she had a toy a chew toy that looked
like a piece of salami
and my dad didn't know that and i was in
the bathroom and my dad cut a piece of
of our chew toy and ate it and again i
still
and he didn't ate it and he put it in
his mouth no he ate it
and then again his brain the synapses
didn't connect
he the taste he he didn't realize it
didn't taste like genoa
my dad's a full monster you just
swallowed
like like like that's that's what do you
call that stuff that's in plastic that
gives you cancer styrofoam or something
i don't know what it is
what's pb free is it um is it uh what is
it called power yeah know
did that swallow in a chew toy before he
realized it doesn't taste like cured
meat yeah he's
he's so so again we have no idea then i
don't know because he doesn't tell me
he thought he just ate a piece of salami
while i was in the bathroom so then we
go out and we always he would take me to
farmer's oval park and ridgewood queens
and we would
i would shoot jump shots and he would
grab the rebounds and then he's grabbing
the reviews and he goes they got a
bathroom over here
and i'm like and then i'm like uh i
don't know dad i mean it's the park he
goes yeah he goes all right let me see
so he comes out there's no bathroom he
goes chris it's an emergency i'm gonna
have to go behind a tree i can't i'm
gonna have to go i'm gonna have to do it
i said what's going on he goes
your mother overcooked the salami again
i swear to god how is your dad not a
billionaire i know he needs his own show
i know and everyone needs to just shut
up well i'll tell you what i had another
i
i'm chrissy the other nickname is
chrissy pilots i'm always i always get a
pilot
and then my show never gets picked up
which is the same i had an animated show
on development for comedy central i was
just told yesterday
it's gone oh yeah that's all right we're
gonna bring new life into that elsewhere
all right
the the buck doesn't stop oh yeah comedy
central my special
size size 36 waist gone uh animated show
guys
it's follow-up to size 38 weeks i was
gonna all the work you did to drop the
two
yeah now it's like [ __ ] with the
depression it might be size 40 weights
now oh my god what can you do either
either one works but i i will
tell you it is my goal in life to have
uh hopefully five comedy specials and
everyone be the waist size it will never
do
that yeah yeah i love yeah i want that
another reason i wanted to do this
podcast
is exactly what just happened so we we
tour together we spend a lot of time
we talk sometimes we're together for
like four five six days in a row morning
noon and night yeah
breakfast lunch and dinner shows green
rooms right yeah and
we have shared a lot of personal stories
absolutely you have
a power a superpower i don't know what
it is and i say this to you all the time
i i i always think i've heard every
story
right and then you you'll drop a story
on me where your dad ate a chew toy
of salami and thought it was real and
then and that almost had to be
hospitalized right
that's like a story you lead with yeah
never heard it
no it did you tell that story or it
didn't occur to you until i said salami
i didn't think does it bang around in
the back and you just never really
i've i've remembered that time but i've
never even thought to say it anywhere
because i
nobody very rarely in my pockets where
you talk about salami right
my point is and i see this you'll talk
like how have you never told me that i
always say that to you
how have you never told me that yeah and
you're like i don't know and i'm like
i never you have it's it's i said people
need to hear these stories yeah well
that this is the podcast where they will
feel like we'll hear them
people need to hear these stories people
need to hear these stories with selling
chris it's on the table yeah it's on the
table
so yeah mike's mike mike's marking it
down on what's on the table homeless
pimp is what we'll
we'll call him homeless pimp but we call
him mike but you guys call him homeless
i asked him uh earlier
talk to you you look great by the way
well you know what it is i'm just trying
to look like
i mean i got my [ __ ] thigh out it's
brutal i'm
putting this here yeah
[Laughter]
now i'm comfortable yeah you look good
thank you i asked him why homeless pimp
and he just said
you know it was it was a name he picked
for his xbox name long ago and it stuck
is that right yeah no it's good well
because it's like you know he's such
a phenomenal uh you know video guy and
and takes phenomenal pictures and it's
just like
we were like he's gonna help us i
thought he's gonna come up here and turn
on
an iphone 7 plus i don't know and then
we were gonna like you know and i was
gonna
there is i don't know people can see
this but there is
there is so much equipment but when he
rang my bell i opened the door
and he had a cart full of like equipment
and he goes i'm gonna need to make
it was already full of equipment yeah
and he goes i'm gonna need to make a
couple a few more trips
i was like whoa this is no deal around i
mean yes
because by the way this is we're coming
live to you from san volcano studios
we're in salvakano's a room in south
house yeah that's it um so so sal's got
one half of his uh apartment is a joke
this is not i don't
keep this up in life i should because
it's funny but i'm not that guy did you
pose for that what's the story with this
no they i did i posed yeah i did so it
was
season four or five they had the idea to
do the ad campaign to be all of us
superimposed into old paintings okay and
so they said i was going to be sal with
the pearl earring and so i
i looked at i literally had the picture
in front of the real one and i was
trying to like
recreate it over the shoulder and then
they sent us this as a gift i thought it
was hysterical
and i ended up putting it up for the
show dinner party with yeah
so i put it up for that as a goof and
then we didn't want it to be a white
wall and so we just kept this up
like it i don't want anyone to think i'm
some type of weird like guy who has oil
paintings of himself
in his house if it's up to me i say we
keep this
until one of the fans of the show would
like to make an oil painting of sal and
chris
that's right then we can move it out
maybe we when we figure out what the
name of the show is
yeah they can make it like an oil
painting and we'll like that'll be the
branding and we'll hang that up here
yeah
that's good um so so uh so
it's a salami so that's you know that's
2001. i want to take it back to 1983.
yeah late 1980 when i was born in august
of 84. so this is the summer of 84.
my mom's um mattingly's rookie year 83
i think it was yeah i'm wearing a
mattingly jersey right now that's very
nice my
my uh mom is laying down you know eight
months pregnant she's got a blanket over
her
they're having a picnic at central park
which i'm sure my father was dr dragged
to
they go my dad says i gotta go take a
piss
goes up in central park in public starts
pissing behind a tree
okay this is real starts peeing behind a
tree
just as as only my dad could do
eventually i want to know what your
dad's parents were like yeah that's what
i want i wanna go i want to i want to
get
there yeah well i think on the show we
can explore that because i've actually
never thought to ask what his parents
were like they both died before i was
born
so but with that my dad's peeing behind
a tree in public in central park sheep's
metal whatever
with that 1984 strawberry fields
everything
just pissing on it dan aykroyd comes
rollerblading by
down i forgot this was about danny yeah
i forgot
and i i just this was like a uh this was
like a a
m night shyamalan type twist for me yeah
yeah dan aykroyd that's what made me
think of it dan aykroyd comes
rollerblading by
stops starts flirting with my mother
my father sees that sees there was a
branch
by a tree chases dan aykroyd with the
dream branch
and akroyd rollerblades
rollerblade spy rollerblades bye
and then with all that it's dan aykroyd
dan
aykroyd it's it's dan eckhart but my dad
that's not his height
at a time but from what my mother said
my dad
yelled at dan aykroyd [ __ ] you bill
murray stay away from my wife
oh that stinks he did stick so he called
him did he know
or did he not know my dad knew that
because dan acquired bill murray were
very famous no but did your dad think he
was bill murray which is what i think
but
if your dad had the wherewithal to call
in the wrong name because he think it
would bite him
in the ass like like insult him or not
no my dad just thought he was bill
murray
i think my dad does boomer because
that's not the first time my father has
done that
did i ever tell you wait
wait i gotta go you you go trading
places and i'll tell you what i don't
even have a story all i'm telling you is
she does full topless in training places
for like extended seconds
she's she's just beautiful all natch wow
natty ice it's in the bank that's in the
back and and god blessed that woman yeah
i love her so much
yeah and now you know i do i see her in
the yoga commercials and i
have fond memories of that yeah yeah
so so she's by the way she's she's she
also was the spokesperson
i've been she was with team when
t-mobile was voice stream like
20-something years ago
she was i believe the face
of all of t-mobile of a voice stream it
was called really yeah she's go she went
home
she went hard in endorsements yeah i
mean that's where the money is active
activity oh activity yeah the only way
cultured yeah the only
active anytime i'm having a problem
pooping activity ah
is where i go yeah yeah hundred percent
now she did she did it halloween again
that's i would love to have her career i
would love to have her on the podcast
i would love to have a career we're
gonna get some great guests on this
podcast that'd be wonderful we're gonna
be fine she's i mean she's probably
listening
yeah i would say yeah jamie lee how are
you jamie lee looks exactly like one of
my aunts
so it's strange sometimes when you know
when you're like oh jamie lee you're a
tractor but it looks like one of my
aunts yeah so what can you do
um but yeah there was a time where my
dad we were sitting at joe's pizza
in the west village we're sitting there
i was about 19. favorite size
fantastic joe's pizza forever new york
hit the west village go to joe's pizza
we're sitting there having a slice and
um
and uh i forgot what we're doing in the
city maybe we're on our way to a next
game or something like that my dad would
always take me
that was my dad's uh incentive for doing
good in school or
cleaning my room whatever it's like we
take go to the next game oh next game
yeah you want to you want to square
slice yeah
so we're there and you know joe's gets a
lot of celebrities that come in there
and steven tyler comes in from aerosmith
oh wow right he comes in
and my dad's like oh this freaking guy
stephen tyler
and he sits starts sitting down stephen
tyler just standing there
starts cutting his pizza with a knife
and a fork
and my dad goes i can't believe this
freaking guy with a knife and a fork
eating the pizza in new york city like
that he goes i got to tell him something
he goes hey bon jovi
that's not how we do this
and then people were like what is bon
jovi because nobody even noticed stephen
tyler i was the only one that noticed
that
so so well not i was the only one wrote
something but he's you know conspicuous
or whatever
and my dad's like yeah i [ __ ] and
then my dad just keeps saying he's like
yeah bon jovi
i i kept saying that there's steven
tyler smith but my you know my dad like
when he dropped me off that night my mom
was like we met bon jovi i'm like it's
not bon jovi
it's not jon bon jovi it's a different
guy it's that my first concert ever
yeah june 29 1989 jon bon jovi bon jovi
uh new jersey
at giant stadium they filmed the video
to lay your hands on me what was that
what's questionable here's the thing
first concert i ever bought a ticket for
was poison
nassar called cm february 14th 1989.
interesting i didn't end up going
right so i it's like the first one i
actually physically went to was bon jovi
i now
have have met bon jovi sweetest guy in
the world
i would i would bon jovi seems like he's
a really just nice down-to-earth guy
he's got a very interesting haircut too
does he still have like his hair
like how's his hair now well don't let
me don't let me that wasn't
i i we don't like i don't know what his
hair looks like right now okay yeah okay
but uh but i i have met him he has
invited us to see him
play uh um his family uh
watched the show and so his wife and
children have been on set and actually
one of his oldest daughters actually is
a colleague of mine really yeah she
works on the show i've been to one
concert and one concert only in my
entire life
and that's britney spears to circus
prudential center newark new jersey
2006. that's the only concert i've ever
been to in my life period i've never
been to a concert
i can't even i can't even i can't even i
don't know where to begin
i feel like i'm like [ __ ] combust
right now
what i don't understand this you
otherwise you you appear normal on the
surface
i know you you've been to one live music
event
concert one live a proper concert you've
been to one in your lifetime
you're in your mid-30s i'm 35 years old
i mean how accurate was that
yeah if you want to consider that
mid-30s
when where when britney spears the
circus to prudential
prudential center in newark new jersey
2006. so 14 years ago when you were 21
years of age yeah
what context did you decide to finally
go to a concert a girlfriend my
girlfriend at the time
said i got last-minute tickets to
britney spears the circus yeah do you
want to come i said you know i've never
been to a concert this will be my first
of many
let's do it i go i had a great time
never went to another concert again
nothing in you loved the 1975. i was
just going to say the 1975 is my
favorite brand i had tickets in my hand
for them
may 25th 2020 msg
pandemic happens old city coveted city
so if i would have been to a second
concert but china got in the way you you
you you don't pine
to to see music or bands that you love
or icons before they go
go away or you don't ever want to be
like or even just a live music
experience
outdoors even right like a central park
lawn or like
or when they have these festivals with
like you know i mean don't get me wrong
i kind of outgrew that a little bit i
don't know
you trudging around in the in the heat
and you really like that that holds you
down with water right so you don't die
i don't want it and i'm sneaking in a
bottle full of vodka like a aquafina
bottle full of
underneath my sack i've done it i've
done it but i'm past it right now i like
to go
in the box if i have the extra money i
spend it and i go and enjoy it like an
adult like an adult like well not an
adult like an older person
right i mean but but i've been to i will
call it
let me think about this first concert
i was uh 12. i was 13.
i was 12. i was 12 and a half and uh why
when do we stop halfs
if i was like i'm if i told you i was 43
and a half would you think anything
different of me
i would think that it's it's odd but i
would say
what i mean you know what i mean why is
it odd i'm literally giving you my age
though yeah
like if i turned 43 yesterday or if i
was going to turn 44 in a week
i would mention that right i'm in the
halfway mark and i say i'm 43 and a half
all of a sudden i'm
i'm some weirdo i've never thought about
that i would say maybe uh
10 you stop like you can't say i'm 10
and a half you know why half you know
why because as a kid you always
you want to prove that you're older than
you are because you that you associate
that with being cooler more mature
hanging out with the older kids getting
allowed to do more things
right you know and then some somewhere
along the line you pump those brakes
yeah when then you start to say i'm in
my early 30s my
mid-30s or my late 30s right which i
mean so now let me ask you this question
when i turn 36
i mean my mid or am i late now am i
going into my latest 30 minutes too late
that's a mouthful though
i'm i'm in my mid to late 30s you say
mid i'm in my mid 30s
34 35 36 is mid 37 i have to
if i'm going to tell the truth to people
which is what i want to do on this
podcast i have to say late mid to late
you're at the end of mid at the
beginning of late right
38 30 39 you have to say i'm in my late
30s then
i'm just about 40 you say probably i'm
just about 40. right
that's terrible yeah it's interesting
did something happen when you turn 40
sorry mentally i tell you i get less
i got less sharp yeah no i um
i four i think 50 is going to be the big
one
50 is the big one 50 and which i'm now
seven years from well not even i'm six
and a half years six and a half years
uh 50 is different 50 is
grandparent age yeah it's uh i think it
is right
yeah well well that's the minus 20 is it
like
if you have a kid let's see if you could
have 25. right and and at 45 your 20
year old has a kid
yeah you could be in your 50s like i i
and my daughter are 30 when i'm 55 yeah
she'll be 25
within reason i know there's younger
grandparents and older but i think
that's right i just think it's like
then you got to get all the tests
everything's got to go up your ass
everything like that i know
and but it's interesting because you
know giannis you know i do the podcast
with giannis history hyenas
and we've been making fun of him because
he's got a kid on the way and he's 45
gonna be 46 so we're like you know when
your kid is in kindergarten
you're gonna be somebody's grandpa i
mean i have to have a family one day
i'm 43 right now i don't have one like
you're gonna be the same boat i'm gonna
be in the exact same boat
i mean but do what does that mean it's
fine never i mean you know i really want
my
you know my parents to know my children
right you know
everyone's healthy so that's what i
think of my mind the most
but also like you know my sister had my
niece very young
my sister had her first child when she
was young
wrong in her 20s but like younger and
now my niece is about to be 20
and my sister is only in you know in her
40s that's i think that like they get a
lot more life together
yeah like i i regret not having do you
wish you would have had children in your
30s i don't regret how my life has gone
and where i am and who i know and how i
spend my time but um i don't know if i
would call it regret
i mean if i had a kid i think a lot of
things would be different right now
right but
also you're telling me that the thing
i'm gonna love the most in this world i
would have had another 20 years with
right so that's a good point i do i do
because i'll say like being a father
like you know i'm 35 of a five-year-old
i felt like having a child at 30 felt
right
for me even though it was a surprise
thing it was nice because i'm like you
know what when she's 21 i'll be 51 not
not certainly not certainly not young
but not so all that i can't do anything
with her and i was just thinking like
you might even like some of the same
music
yeah absolutely i think you said you
might even like some of her friends
you might even you might even be able to
hook up you want to go to concert number
two
yeah yeah which one of you um no so so i
feel like it's a nice
nice place but you know being you split
the difference
i split the difference but you know
being a parent it's just like
you got to be able to sacrifice you know
it's just there's so much sacrificing
that goes on
like i still feel very young you know
being in my in my mid-30s
my me i'm approaching my mid approaching
my mid to late 30s
i i approaching midfield
yeah so i find that
the thing that you know the only drop
not that there's a drawback but it's
just like you know there's a lot of time
a lot of my friends don't have kids yet
and they're getting to do
not getting they're doing fun things
going to bars doing things like that
where
i'm not i can't do that because i'm like
you know what
my daughter are doing that but where if
we're a guy like if you're saying
when you want to start a family if
you're 45 i think the urge
in your mid 40s to go out and want to
stay out to four o'clock the morning is
almost non-existent as compared to those
thirties it does not exist so it doesn't
exist so in other words you're
naturally you what the hell you want to
you're going to say only a kid anyway
where sometimes with me
and my kid's mom we're like still young
enough we're like oh we want to go out
to five in the morning
once in a while but we don't and it's
not that it's a big deal but
that is i think a benefit of having a
child later is your body and mind
regardless was already like i'm [ __ ]
done with the party sure but then if
but then if i croak at 75 i don't really
have any time with anybody
it really it's a real tragedy yeah but i
mean do you really want to live i mean
you know who are these people that want
to live to 130 anyway i mean
i wouldn't mind it as long as i'm not
just like dragging myself around
yeah you know i don't want to i don't
know if i really want a fun old guy i
don't want to l i don't know if i want
to live to see what the [ __ ] going to
happen with this earth
yeah you know but then again if i bring
a kid into it they gotta deal with it
right i don't know it's a tough time to
think about having a kid but like
i'm ready like if i don't have it now
like if i don't have one i i need to
have
start a family sooner than later right
because that kid's not at like
50 something i mean people are doing it
but it's so not ideal
also like taking apple cider vinegar
what's going on but i i have been i
haven't you know like the last decade
i've been just
busting my ass with work and i guess you
always find a way to make it work but if
i'd like had a kid
maybe i wouldn't have been able to push
the limits and create as many
opportunities
you never know i don't know i don't
really know now we're also the ultimate
font you're all the ultimate funkle i
would think is mr salvato i take a lot
of pride in that yeah
i like basically like basically i have
kids i raised like i helped raise i
don't say help raise but like yeah i was
very very prominent in every niece and
nephew's life uh
i could i was in shock one day when i
saw
i came into the house and we were
hanging out
and i saw what i thought was a script i
was like oh what'd you get like a new
movie role they're like no that's my
christmas list for my family i mean this
guy must
have about a hundred pages of items
for yeah everybody is saying if you are
a member of the salvador family
you're getting a christmas gift it
doesn't [ __ ] matter how extended it
is
you're getting a gift i didn't know you
saw that i mean it was it was a list
like this and i was like that's that's
how you know i'm a big christmas guy
though
i'm a big christmas guy and i'm a big
family guy you put those together it's
fire now are you do you play santa for
the kids are you i did my whole life
yeah yeah i did i did um i used to put
the thing on they put them to bed
yeah and then i i wake them up cold yeah
so they disheveled yeah but i had the
glasses and the beard so they wouldn't
know it was me
yeah then when they get like a little
older i would like ring the bell and
drop the prints off and then like
they'd hear me at the front door right
but then when they woke up and they got
to their door across the hall
i'd be at the at the at the front door
being like thank you
yeah because at that point like i didn't
want to recognize me yeah and then
then then a really tragic thing happened
one time i was going to do it
and my youngest at the time and i have a
new a new
one-year-old and a one a one-year-old
nephew a two-year-old niece and i have
younger nephews that live across the
country but for here like um
sometimes they'll visit for christmas
but when it's just the family here
i had my my youngest niece at the time
was like 10. yeah
and you know the older ones get in their
ear and then maybe the younger ones find
out a little sooner than the older ones
did because
they have an in yeah like an informant
yeah and then
i was like oh you gotta go to bed you
know you gotta um
tiana's coming tonight and then like i
saw the youngest one
with the second youngest one look and
share look like i know and
know what they would do and then is how
i don't reveal santa's yeah
yeah i don't reveal the truth about
santa whatever that may be right
i don't know who's listening to this but
what i what i realize is i'm keep i'm
protecting them and keeping the magic
alive
the role reversed and they didn't tell
me
that they already had an idea to protect
me to save my magic because they know
how magical it is
that i love that they broke your heart
they broke my heart but they no they
didn't want to they didn't show me that
they knew
right they shared a look with each other
i caught the look but it's to say as
let's go to bed but we know that we know
what's going on we know what's going on
and
then they didn't look at me and so when
they walked in the room i actually shed
tears
yeah because i was like the like the
hunt like not this
not this but like the hunter becomes the
hunted yeah not that but something
flipped there the script was flipped and
they were protecting me from not knowing
that they knew
the truth about whatever you want to
tell your kids the truth about santa you
believe you see that
that's uh that's a wet and that's like
how life works eventually you start
taking care of your parents like they
took care of you
exactly i found out santa wasn't real
again all true story queen sent to mall
oh yeah alleged
alleged oh yeah right i found out
allegedly santa's still not real
1991 i'm seven years old i never even
thought about
questioning you know this this person
but 1991 queen center mall where i would
always go to get pictures uh
taken for um you know with santa it's a
different santa nice blue-eyed santa
my mother's you know young pretty woman
as i said
my mother and santa hit it off
they start dating
you see what i'm saying do you see what
i'm saying we've maybe
logged in 20 000 hours of conversation
before this i've never heard this
how do you not lead with these stories i
just i don't because i don't i
started banging the mall santa and maul
santa
oh my god my mom so so then
goes on a date with the mall santa and
has to
tell me that january february that
that's where they met because i said
cause i heard them talking and i knew
who it was
and my mom just had to say listen that's
not saying it's gary
[Music]
so my mom dated gary oh for about two
years but
the positive things and also that's
seasonal what's gary doing for scott
when he's when he's not there oh so use
car salesman
no he wants to swear he was a
dual used car salesman slash mall santa
gary nissan on northern boulevard
wow yeah unbelievable yep so but why
didn't she just tell you that
that was santa's helper because because
why did your world have to come crashing
down around you because it was 1991 was
either christmas gifts or a really good
deal
on on an altima so because 1991
gary claus what instead of
don't forget there's no cell phones not
a digital world right gary didn't want
to let
my mom slip away because he really felt
he had a connection so he had to put me
down
and get one of his elves to go get a pen
and paper so he could write down my
mother's phone number
and there was nothing there was no way
that this couldn't happen in front of me
so i watched this whole thing happen and
the only option after that after they
hit off and started to
actually officially date was to tell me
that hey chris
again you're kid you know this guy you
know
gary is sam gary's not the real santa so
then i said
how does gary like what is how does gary
get the gifts
to everybody like what is gary you know
like i don't understand like
so gary is you're dating like the real
guy
your your brain is not putting you cause
i'm like you know i see everywhere like
is gary like are we safe like what is a
major celebrity like i was like can he
introduce me to michael jordan like
you know like i was like who could what
can i get out of gary
sure like go to school and be like yeah
my mom dates santa so yeah
if you guys need anything i'm the guy so
so
and then they but you know it to prevent
me from thinking that you know gary's
actually standing and
[ __ ] my mind they just told me hey
you know it's the thing that we tell
people but what gary and i have is real
love and that's real and talking about
real love
and then they broke up i wanted gary
ruined christmas ruined christmas
and then my dad was pissed about that my
dad was like it's bad enough
you got to bring gary in but now you
know he ruins freaking santa wow
everybody on my mother was like tony
you're in prison
you're not doing much better here you're
calling us from jail
[Laughter]
wait gary where's gary today how long
did they date
they dated i hope it was long otherwise
you you got spared christmas for no
reason the back-to-back boyfriends my
mom dealt with were
one was gary claus santa ruined it then
don't tell me it was the [ __ ]
more easter bunny no the next could you
imagine the next guy she dated the next
guy she dated this guy
chuck okay from vermont they went on a
few dates chuck
chuck i'm like waiting oh my god what is
this gonna be
yeah chuck comes you know visits my mom
they go on a few dates he's staying in a
hotel really likes my mom whatever
tells my mom to i want you to come
to vermont you know and hang out with me
for a weekend my mom's like excited but
you know
i don't know if i want to go to vermont
i get strep throat which i get strep
throat constantly i still get strep
though i understand so i got strep
throat
my mom has to cancel with chuck chuck
flips out
like you know really angers my mother
whatever they you know mom's like i'm
not talking to this guy anymore it's
like it's my son i'm sorry i can't make
the weekend whatever flips out
that night goes and kills a bartender
in some local bar in vermont life in
prison
so they they it's it's my so my mother
was dated
santa and then a murderer back
are you like witness protection yo yeah
no you
chuck flipped out that you couldn't go
to vermont and killed somebody
life in prison life in prison to this
day he might be able to the podcast i
know what the new prison rules you know
this is
this is how this is going in like four
podcasts you're gonna mention that chuck
was also
your dad's prison inmate but you just
decided not to mention that either well
how about this
how about this how about this put it on
the door on the list
so so so 91 to 91 93 95
is is every other year it gets wild so
91 my mom dates santa
93 chuck chuck to murderer 95 check the
winner check the murderer there's a
rekindling
there's a rekindling of my mother and my
father comes back my father that i knew
about
so my fault do you know what happens
though
okay so 95 my father comes back he's in
the house south for a week
one week this i i okay i i don't
remember but
i remember it was announced for a week
i'm excited i'm like you know like you
know if like first it was santa
now it's not then that guy murders
finally i got my dad back right i feel
safe
everything's good so the knicks are
playing the pacers
in in the finals oh yeah that was that
was what reggie miller
again eastern conference finals yeah my
dad's a big compulsive gambler you know
like that's why i got thrown around in
the first place gambles whatever
we're in there week my mother's cooking
dinner it's a beautiful beautiful
saturday
it's amazing i can still smell the
mashed potatoes
patrick ewing goes up for a finger roll
at the buzzer when he should have dunked
the ball that would
beat the pacers and they would have
moved on remember the finger roll backs
out
uh but you know finger roll instead of
dunking it backs off the
bounce off the back rim my dad says
[ __ ] ewing every time
grabs a trophy that was on a shelf right
behind the couch
throws it through the tv my mother
doesn't even turn around
goes tony pack your [ __ ] up and get out
last time my father was ever in my
[Laughter]
sweet house yeah so that's what it is oh
yeah
you know how i was saying like i don't
um like any confrontation
uh i'll piggyback real quick on the
santa yeah i lose my first tooth
okay first one i get him i get all the
teeth right and now i lose them
under the pillow my mom tells me you
know oh you know you tooth fairy and i
i heard about the tooth fairy i had
friends that lost some teeth before yeah
yeah and i said all right it's a tooth
fairy and she says yeah so um
but i never really thought about the
tooth fairy
until it was i lost a tooth i knew it of
what it
was but i never really thought about
coming into contact with the tooth fairy
right until i lost my first one right so
here comes i lose it
and she we're going to bed and she puts
the
tooth in the envelope right and she's
saying goodnight to me she's putting
under my pillow and i saw this is this
is terrific so uh
you know at some point then she's yeah
the tooth fairy's gonna come middle of
the night
right and which i knew but again now all
of a sudden it's real
right it's real now at some point
they'll approach you but however she
said it however she said it didn't sound
great
right at some time a woman will enter
this home tonight
she will approach you uh while you
slumber yeah and she will
put her hands underneath the pillow
where you sleep she'll take what she
needs and she'll put what she needs
there
and she'll leave and you'll never know
like that she didn't say that but
but she said that two phrases are coming
the middle of the night and she's gonna
swap this out
and i said well how's she getting in the
house or whatever why well she just it's
like a magical whatever she said magical
things she gets in here
so she can enter in and exit anytime she
wants like you would never know
right now well she just comes when
you're missing teeth whatever yeah
what if i don't you know i wanted to
come or whatever right well no you lost
a tooth you put on you can get money or
whatever and i said
all right but i don't know man so
she said goodnight she went inside put
to turn the lights off i laid there
sweating bullets for about i'll say i
call it three hours
right sweating bullets right i went
under the covers
to the i was sealed right i was yellow
and blue makes green it's sealed
blocked myself yeah i was high probably
breathing in
co2 like nobody's gonna say i can't
believe carbon monoxide i know and and
and i'm soaked i'm soaked and i'm
envisioning
outside the comforter this woman that
the tooth fairy
she wasn't nice looking right she was
like almost like the tooth fairy but
like she just wasn't pleasant at all
yeah and i just finally freaked the [ __ ]
out i whipped the covers off of me
and i and uh oh no no no no no i dozed
eventually i dozed this is gonna happen
i dozed eventually and i woke up and i
was like
and i just was like i reached under my
pillow and i was like please don't tell
me this woman came
and i i pulled out an envelope full of
coins
and i knew it was heavy and it shook and
i went to jingjing and i knew
immediately she had been there
right and i freaked the [ __ ] out i went
ah
and i was like what's the matter she
comes running i go oh this lady came in
[ __ ] coins i don't wanna know i could
i get cause i knew
i had to lose it more teeth and i can't
stop that that's just
biology right so i was like i don't even
want to see this woman again
no no i scream she she literally was
like i was hyperventilating she goes
come with me
she walked me down the hallway into the
kitchen showed me the tooth
the envelope with my tooth in it right
there and said i'm the tooth fairy okay
wow i'm the truth so first tooth first
night three hours in i've never believed
in a tooth fairy ever since then
i did work out a deal where she gave me
money for interchange for the tooth but
we handed it off to each other
yeah i was like hey i got it yeah i got
you delivery but now let me ask you this
quick
same reason i wouldn't go to machine i
still i don't know i wouldn't what do i
call a tooth fairy but did you do the
thing that i did when it happened with
gary
did you think that now the tooth fairy
is made up but you just think your
mother
you're the son of the actual tooth fairy
no i knew my mother told me a tall tale
right and that it was all [ __ ] and
then from then i wonder if i
extrapolated that and was like what
exactly
is real because i never really bought
into the easter bunny ever anyway right
because the easter bunny's not a human
so you look at sandy like that's an old
guy with a with a thing and he does what
he does
right but i knew that that wasn't a
bunny i've never seen a bunny like that
before
right right a bunny is in his he's he's
zipped up yeah
santa is a human he's flesh he's flat
yeah yeah i was never really buying into
the bunny into the bunny yeah but now
once that came into play the tooth fairy
i was probably got cynical at an age
when i really shouldn't have started to
get cynical but she had to do that for
me to stop
to go back to bed and stop
hyperventilating because i was so
nervous because if you think about it
it's really not like it's like this
person's going to come through the walls
and you're going to be sleeping and then
she's going to fiddle around yeah you
know while you're sleeping
it's it's the tooth fairy is one of
those things where it's like yeah when
my daughter loses her first tooth
i don't know what to do it's also like
yeah like
especially with even like corona it's
like am i going to put a a
germ corro am i going to put a a dollar
bill under her i mean she could get
covert in the eye right
so now it's like i guess i'll just vent
i got to venmo venmower
[Laughter]
from the toothpaste tooth fairy at
gmail.com and they're like just check if
you have anything from her
yeah she's like because of covert she
can't go to houses she can't go to
houses tooth fairy it's too much germs
yeah and there's
two favorite ways of making it
everything's hysterical you're gonna
have to venmo
everything i'm gonna that's what it is
santa can't come in either no
nobody's coming not unless you got a
mask on you like i think it was a part
the fact that like santa doesn't really
come in your bedroom no
santa goes in the living room unless you
sleep unless your room is the one that
has the chimney which it's just bad luck
yeah but that's the odds are low
yeah that's a low if you're the baby
with the chimney in your room yeah i
mean i
mean i don't even know i only know three
people that had the chimney in their
rooms and i know they're all [ __ ] up
now man no but like
santa's going into communal space other
people are in the home
yeah but this woman thinks she's going
to sneak in the middle of night in the
dark come
in my room this is a safety zone well
let me ask yeah because the thing is
with santa now it's like let me ask you
this
stan okay so santa comes to my house i
live in new york when he goes to florida
is he waiting there for 14 days is he
quarantining
after he drops those pictures you can't
it can't unless unless someone's going
to drop us a memo
that christmas is is is is months long
yeah he can't do his job under the
current conditions and he's not above
the law
no he bet well he may think he is but i
get i
tell you what he's going to find out
that would be an interesting december
absolutely it's going to be very first
one of our lives yeah because how is he
going to get all these gifts with
quarantine i don't know how he's going
to do it
and then yeah am i do i have to
disinfect i don't know what the hell's
going on in the north pole would have
been there or should have they were they
like sweden where everything was open
what are the corona numbers so they go
year round they don't have time to sleep
they have no time they're telling me if
one gets in if one
[ __ ] dopey elf gets infected they're
all gone that's it they're all done
sneezy you think i'm [ __ ] trust
season easy
[Music]
fixing blicks and steve oh snow caesar's
one
[Laughter]
i don't care if he has a mask on if
you're just sneezing non-stop behind the
mask
oh i don't care that n95 is gonna it
only has so much power in it no
no yeah so i'm holding power i got
nothing to do no you ever see a sneeze
in slow motion on youtube
it's disgusting don't you ever seen a
fart on on uh
uh oh the red light yeah yeah
yeah we're going to look at those once
we get this the studio up to
where we're going to have it that's
gonna be the first video we watch yeah
you and by the way if you've never seen
a sneak like a slow motion sneeze
i'm gonna tell you don't don't go look
at it because
i live my life a certain way because
i've been exposed to things like this
right
you see when someone sneezes it is
similar to like someone bombing us
really like it is it is
billions i mean you can't even it comes
out at 100 miles an hour
and it covers the whole room in the
cloud of the of their germs and
that's what they're saying like droplets
you know drops right yeah like we're
throwing droplets back and forth right
now we're doing it right now which is
also why i was hesitant to do any shows
right because if we're doing our job
right everyone's laughing and coughing
and
and slapping and yeah yeah and that's
what
going to do everywhere that's like yeah
good news for you though
and and me and doing this podcast is i
have a deviated septum so i can't get a
sneeze out
so i'll always i'll always be and it
won't come out you don't sneeze
i've never produced a sneeze in my life
i swear to god this is quiet
yes it's very wet and i've went you know
one concert never sneezed
never sneezed no goat cheese no no pork
chop
never saw trading places yeah never saw
santa was my stepfather yeah
santa was just have fun yeah that is
we didn't know what it's going to be i
don't know could it still be i mean
listen in post we could do anything
i still i like sal and chris present hey
babe but then we also have a couple of
them we said
going to tell you this did you write
them down mike you'll have to listen
back
let's sit back but there's a couple of
ideas in there that we can listen back
did i did it
yeah i forgot what they were let me tell
you this did i ever tell you i'll tell
you that everything
about this one i forgot what about that
yeah so they're all good
it's all good we're still we're still
figuring it out by the time this comes
out maybe we'll have banked a couple and
decided on our own
yeah or no or this does this come out
with no name no we could i know because
this is going to come out with name
so we will have decided well if by
anything well at least we'll we'll do
and before this podcast episode
once we've signed a name we'll say hey
guys you're listening to whatever we say
and then the episode
but the people are hearing this right
now we might as well just leave this in
i want to do no edits
besides the one thing that i said yeah i
want to do no edits besides if it's a
huge mistake but other than that we'll
just you know
like no rules right no rules no rules
because like if we want to do a whole
episode
on like a true or something true crime
like you can do that brought that up too
yeah like whatever interests us whatever
whatever whatever it is whatever it is
yeah i've been watching ancient aliens
i'd love to talk to you about that
yeah all right there it is so that's for
i i liked it i liked it
so much an hour this was this is exactly
like what what
what we do in the hotel room with no mic
all right
[Music]